All my toddlers were playing in the backyard.
They asked me for a Capri Sun,
and since I had all the fruit at home to make some,
I told them to give me a minute while I got started.
Favorite one is the multivitamin,
so. So I decided to use some pineapple, pears,
apple oranges, and also some frozen cherries.
I took the skin off my pineapple,
chopped it up, before moving on to my pear and doing the exact same.
Peeled my oranges, cut those into slices,
and then moved on to doing the same with my Granny Smith apple.
Once all of my fruit was chopped,
I put it all in a bowl. I also added some cold grapes.
Then it was time to start juicing all of my fruit.
I started with my pineapple,
moved on to my cherries, and then did all the pineapple after.
Once everything was juiced,
I passed it through a fine mesh strainer
and then added some water to thin it out.
You can add as much or as little water as you want.
Then filled it into their little pouches before grabbing two straws,
opening those up, and our Capri Sun was done.
They were so excited to have this and couldn't wait.
And right as I was done cleaning up, they wanted a second one.